nate's when it comes to a great steak a
lot goes into it
the cut the seasoning how you cook it
and the cow's diet
here to tell us more is sam marvin the
owner of echo and rig at tivoli village
welcome sam how is a cow's diet how does
that play a role into the perfect steak
it's unbelievable how much importance it
takes onto it right the fuel what it
eats what it eats is what you eat
right so if it's eating grass it's fresh
it's light it's vibrant
if it's eating grain it's luscious it's
fatty it's
it's it's filled with richness now you
have a you have a butcher shop
so how can i tell where what what the
cows died our butcher we
label everything and you can ask any
butcher so wherever you go there's a
label that'll let you know if it's grass
fed grain fed so on and so forth
but the butcher's the best guy to talk
to that is a trick and he brought some
special meat first today and you're
going to make steak tartare of course
i am it's a raw beef dish right steak
tartare we're using a grass-fed steak
we're using the knuckle
which is underneath the kneecap very
lean very flavorful
if you can't find the knuckle from your
butcher shop ask him for fillet or new
york also works well now where's this
meat from
this is from tasmania this is a cattle
from tasmania it's a grass-fed cattle
that's just
probably the best in the world it looks
literally so what we do is we take our
beautiful
lean you see how there's no fat in it
yeah just slice it white yeah we're just
making little tiny
cubes right some people grind it but you
know what
we want to taste the texture of that
beef as well right so we take all this
beautiful beef i got a little bit that i
cut a little earlier all right right
little cubes and we're going to throw it
into a bowl
and it's okay just like that eat the raw
meat like this if it's good meat right
if you're eating raw hot dogs i don't
know right but if you're eating
a hot dog tartare right absolutely it's
full of vitamins and nutrients and
minerals and proteins and
potassium and you name it so we take the
beef and we don't want to hide the
flavor
we're adding a little bit of a chops
capers and corny shones corny stones are
little
baby gherkin cucumbers tiny cucumbers
right and the capers we chop it all up
we're adding a little bit of jalapeno a
little spicy right to give it a little
spice for sure
a little bit of chives which is an onion
family right
get about 45 seconds here we go like
this a little bit of
lemon juice a little bit of olive oil
a little bit of salt we mix the whole
thing up like this
and you sell all this seasoning at the
butcher shop we do and we sell steak
tartares in the restaurant that sells
off the charts
but people don't seem to want to do
steak tartare at home which i don't
blame them because they might not know
where the cattle comes from right well
it's kind of like
a sushi oh maybe a little hesitant but
you make it look so easy look at how
easy it is there's a caper berry for a
little bit of uh
i got about 15 seconds i have to eat
this
dig right in let's go get that let's see
here
steak tartare at its freshest wow you're
tasting the beef
wow wow where am i going here
thank you so much
we'll be right back